N
THE NORTH LAWN, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Bret: LET'S BRING IN THE
PRESIDENT OF FINLAND;
MR. PRESIDENT, THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Bret: YOU SHARE A LONG BORDER
WITH RUSSIA.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE MAP, YOU
COULD DRAW ALMOST A PERFECT
TRIANGLE TO MOSCOW, KYIV, AND
HELSINKI.
HOW DO YOU SEE THE LAST 8, 9
DAYS?
>> , LIKE I GUESS ALL OF US, WE
ARE VERY SURPRISED, SOMETHING
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE HAS TAKEN
PLACE.
NO ONE COULD HAVE IMAGINED THAT
IN EUROPE, IN 2020, SOMETHING
LIKE THIS WOULD HAPPEN.
AND SEEMS TO CONTINUE.
IT IS -- IT'S TRAGEDY.
>> Bret: YOU HAD A MEETING TODAY
WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN IN THE OVAL
OFFICE.
HOW DID YOU TAKE THAT MEETING
AND WHAT DID YOU TAKE AWAY FROM
IT.
>> WE DISCUSSED QUITE A LOT NOT
ONLY THE CURRENT SITUATION IN
UKRAINE, WE TALKED ALSO ABOUT
RUSSIA.
ABOUT CHINA.
BUT ALSO FROM THE NORDIC
COUNTRIES.
AND HOW DO WE TAKE THIS?
>> Bret: DO YOU WANT TO JOIN
NATO NOW?
>> WELL, WE HAVE A STRANGE
SITUATION IN BOTH IN FINLAND AND
SWEDEN.
FOR THE FIRST TIME WE SEE THAT
MATURITY OF PEOPLE ARE PRO,
ACCORDING TO THE POLLS.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING WE ARE NOW
OPEN TO DISCUSSING WITH OUR
PARLIAMENT.
WE TRY TO DEFINE ALL THE
CIRCUMSTANCES, ALL THE RISKS,
AND ALL THE BENEFITS.
AND TO DOING THAT QUITE
EFFICIENTLY AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
>> Bret: MR. PRESIDENT, THERE IS
AN ARTICLE IN THE ATLANTIC
COUNCIL IT, SAYS WILL FINLAND
AND SWEDEN JOIN NATO NOW?
A QUOTE FROM THAT, FOR FINLAND,
THE SHADOW OF HISTORY IS ALWAYS
PRESENT.
AN 833-MILE LONG BORDER WITH
RUSSIA MEANS THAT FINLAND KNOWS
IT CAN NEVER TAKE ITS
SOVEREIGNTY FOR GRANTED.
FINS HAVEN'T FORGOTTEN SOVIET
DEMANDS ON LAND AND HARBORS IN
1939 WHILE SECRETLY PRECINCT FOR
AN INVASION WHICH MOSCOW
LAUNCHED IN NOVEMBER OF THAT
YEAR.
THERE IS A LOT OF HISTORY.
THAT MAY BE WILL LEAN YOU NOW
CONSIDERING WHAT'S HAPPENING
TOWARDS GETTING INTO NATO.
>> YES.
BACK TO 1939, EXCEPT THAT RUSSIA
ATTACKED WE PROTECTED AND
DEFENDED OUR COUNTRY.
THEY DIDN'T COME IN.
ONE HAS TO REMEMBER THAT.
AND SURELY, THAT REMINDS THE
SITUATION IN UKRAINE AT THE
MOMENT.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER, ALSO, THAT
FINLAND HAS MAYBE WE HAVE A BIT
DIFFERENTLY THAN MANY EUROPEAN
COUNTRIES.
WE HAVE ALL THE TIME, HAVE BEEN
VERY KEEN ON DEVELOPING OUR OWN
DEFENSE FORCES, WHICH ARE QUITE
STRONG ONES.
SO, THAT'S ONE ELEMENT
PROTECTING SUCCESS.
AND EUROPEAN UNION, IF NOW MAYBE
MORE UNITED THAN EVER.
WE SEE ALSO GERMANY TAKING
STRONG POSITION ON DEFENSE
SECTOR.
THAT MEANS THAT ALSO EUROPE WILL
COVER MORE SECURITY.
AND THE THIRD ELEMENT IS
MEMBERSHIP OF NATO.
LIKE I SAID THAT IS UNDER
DISCUSSION IN FINLAND.
>> Bret: YOU ALREADY SPEND MORE
THAN 2% OF YOUR G.D.P. ON
DEFENSE FORCES.
YOU MENTIONED GERMANY.
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN
TALKED TO THE CHANCELLOR OF
GERMANY TODAY.
ACCORDING TO THE READ OUT, HE
DENIED THAT RUSSIAN FORCES ARE
BOMBING UKRAINIAN CITIES.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
YOU HAVE MET HIM A NUMBER OF
TIMES.
YOU HAVE HAD A LOT OF MEETINGS.
MANY MORE, PERHAPS, THAN OTHER
LEADERS IN THE REGION.
HAVE YOU NOTICED A CHANGE IN
PUTIN?
>> IF YOU FOLLOW HIS SPEECHES
AND OPINIONS, DURING DECADES, HE
HAS ALWAYS SHOWED SOME KIND OF
BITTERNESS AND EVEN HATRED.
BECAUSE HE HAS SAID MOTHER
RUSSIA HAS BEEN MISTREATED.
AND THIS KIND OF AN ATTITUDE HAS
INCREASED YEAR AFTER YEAR.
NOW THAT WE ALL HAVE SEEN HOW,
ANY WAY LONELY HE SEEMS TO BE
AND MAKES BIG DISTANCE TO OTHER
PEOPLE IT'S NOT POSSIBLE FOR A
PERSON LIVE ONLY WITH HIS BITTER
AND HATE.
THAT MIGHT INCREASE IN HIS
THINKING.
SO, WILL MAYBE -- HUH?
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK THAT HE
WILL EXPAND BEYOND UKRAINE?
>> ALREADY SO FAR SOMETHING WE
CONSIDERED AS IMPOSSIBLE.
AND IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
PREDICT WHAT HE IS GOING TO DO
NEXT.
BUT NOW IT SEEMS THAT HE IS
GOING FORWARD AND DESTROYING
UKRAINE.
>> Bret: LAST THING,
MR. PRESIDENT.
THE NATO SECRETARY GENERAL HAS
SAID THAT NATO WARPLANES WILL
NOT DO A NO-FLY ZONE.
>> WE UNDERSTAND THE
DESPERATION.
BUT ALSO BELIEVE THAT IF WE DID
THAT, WE'LL END UP WITH
SOMETHING THAT COULD END IN A
FULL-FLEDGED WAR IN EUROPE
INVOLVING MANY MORE COUNTRIES.
>> I ASSUME YOU AGREE WITH THAT
BUT WHERE DO YOU THINK THIS IS
GOING.
>> SURELY IT'S A NATO DECISION.
BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT NOW
EVERYBODY WANTS TO AVOID MORE
ESCALATION, WHICH IS ALL THE
TIME VERY NEARBY.
THERE MIGHT BE EVEN ACCIDENTAL
DEEDS, WHICH SUDDENLY BREAK OUT
AND IF WE HAVE ESCALATION, WE
HAVE HUGE WAR IN FRONT OF US.
SO, TRYING TO SAFEGUARD THAT, I
THINK, IS THE REASON WHY NATO IS
NOT PRESENT.
>> Bret: PRESIDENT OF FINLAND,
MR. PRESIDENT, WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME ON "SPECIAL